bonjour bienvenue sur chronique de profs
la chaîne nous maintenant on partage
plus que des campagnes de financement
participatif apparemment non plus
sérieusement les prochains chronique de
profs ne vont pas tarder à sortir je
viens tout juste de terminer les
recherches qui étaient très longue mais
ça va être un sujet que moi je trouve
passionnant et j'espère qu'il vous
plaira bref tout ça pour vous dire que
j'ai écrit une nouvelle qui fait partie
d'un recueil de nouvelles qui s appelle
les chroniques de keane donc c'est une
chronique de dark fantasy si vous aimez
les ambiances un petit peu la fantasy
sombre comme son nom l'indiqué peut-être
même un petit peu lovecraftien par
certains aspects avec un univers un peu
étrange de créatures gigantesques et
blizzard bref et bien les chroniques de
keane pourrait vous plaire dans ce cas à
la base c'est un projet collaboratif
les premiers des premiers chapitres
enfin les premières nouvelles qui
constitue le roman ont été écrites par
un seul auteur et ensuite il a invité
bas tout le tout les auteurs et aux tris
qu'il souhaitait à participer au projet
et vous même d'ailleurs vous le pouvez
si vous voulez ce recueil de nouvelles
est disponible en ligne sur les
chroniques de keane point fr ou coop en
bref le lien apparaît là et vous pouvez
lire certaines des nouvelles mais pas
tout puisque le but est de sortir un
format papier qui contiendra toutes les
nouvelles et pour ça donc on en revient
à l'idée de départ il ya une campagne de
financement qui est en cours vous pouvez
la retrouver aussi dans le lien qui
apparaît ici et dans la description et
sur les réseaux sociaux fait un bref un
petit peu partout donc il reste encore
une 15-20 jours pour cette campagne de
financement et j'espère qu'elle portera
ses fruits parce que c'est vraiment un
beau projet il y avait aussi un court
métrage qui pourrait voir le jour si on
en a les moyens
donc si le financement est atteint on
pourra sortir le livre en papier
rémunérer un petit peu toutes les
personnes qui ont participé au projet
prévoir des goodies intéressant pour
voilà pourtant les contributeurs bref ça
va être sympa voilà donc n'hésitez pas à
les consulter le lien à le partager a
donné de l'argent si vous pouvez si ça
vous intéresse s et en attendant moi je
vous retrouve comme je le disais très
bientôt pour un chronique de profs qui
je pense sortira soit fin octobre soit
début novembre et ça tombe bien parce
que l'ambiance sera un petit peu sombre
également et j'aime bien faire ça au
moment d'halloween voilà arrivés de
l'automne ça la colle bien et ça sera le
ton du chronique de profs du coup merci
beaucoup